the explosions echoed for hours while
Russia Unleashed drone strike after
drone strike
the biggest attack of its kind since the
start of the war
it buzzed and buzzed all night says this
woman there are simply No More Words
the onslaught killed a 41 year old man
and sent a 35-year-old woman to hospital
it also damaged the Ukrainian Society of
the blind
they would come here to chat says this
member this was like their home
the Ukrainian Air Force says it shot
down more than 50 iranian-made drones
The Raid coincided with kieve day which
marks the city's founding almost 1600
years ago what Russia is trying to do in
all this is to try and drain Ukrainian
uh air defense uh missiles rockets and
such ahead of its uh anticipated highly
anticipated uh spring counter offensive
that should be coming any any day or any
week now a top Ukrainian security
official wouldn't name a date but
insisted that counter-offensive is
imminent the Kremlin issued its own
warning in an interview with the BBC
Russia's ambassador to the UK says
Moscow has not started to act seriously
yet in Ukraine it's a big
idealistic mistake to think that Ukraine
may prevail which Russia is 16 times
bigger than Ukraine obviously if they
could
escalate and Conquer Ukraine sooner and
quicker they would Russia's Ally Iran
has provided Moscow with weapons
throughout the conflict like the drones
used in this latest attack as a result
Ukraine's president wants to slap
sanctions on the Iranian regime for 50
years
rate Global News Ottawa